is my pleasure to introduce the next two
speakers uh we're gonna be talking about
improving Traffic Safety through video
analysis in Jakarta Indonesia
aniket concering is a JD student at Yale
University and a PhD candidate in Jews
jurisprudence and Social Policy at the
University of California Berkeley
specializes in law and economics and law
and data science his main research
interest is in information privacy in
cyber security law and also has ongoing
projects dealing with digital consumer
protections smart cities and trademark
law also what introduced rush sets of
edgy versa J is a computer science
master student at Wits University in
South Africa her research interests
include applying machine learning to
help solve problems experienced by
countries in the developing world her
master's work is about using satellite
imagery and computer vision to study the
effects and evolution of spatial
apartheid in South Africa and she is a
recipient of the data science for social
good fellowship at the University of
Chicago without further ado thank you
all right good afternoon everybody we're
really excited to follow this last panel
because this is a really great example
we think of really applying AI to social
good and what it takes to work with
organization and really embed yourself
in a local context to do that so as you
could see we worked on improving traffic
traffic safety through video analysis in
Jakarta Indonesia and we're really
excited to show you the results of a
collaboration between three really
fantastic organizations that were able
to achieve exactly that so first data
science for social good at the
University of Chicago that's where the
two of us came from along with our
colleagues it's a summer fellowship
hosted by you Chicago we were there this
past summer and it basically brings
together graduate students across data
sciences so computer science statistics
the social sciences to partner with
local governments NGOs on other
organizations that our aim
to have a public policy or social policy
impact our partners this summer were in
the city of Jakarta so as you could see
Jakarta smart City is a new city agency
that is dedicated to bringing data
science and data-driven tools to various
agencies throughout the city of Jakarta
across field such as transportation
health education and other areas of
social policy pulse labs Jakarta is a
branch of the United Nations Global
pulse which is also an agency that deals
with data analysis data science and
other data-driven techniques and
analysis
to enable cities and states across the
entire world to make better social
policy decisions so before we get into
the technical aspects of what we did I
first wanted to pause and talk a little
bit about what it takes to really frame
a social policy social problem like this
and then tackle it with the technical
solution so Jakarta is a city in
transition it has grown from a
population of a little over two million
in 1970 to over 10 million today
becoming the largest city in Southeast
Asia with that growth also comes a
massive growth in the wealth of its
citizens and with that wealth comes more
things like car ownership motorcycle
ownership the city has grown and
sprawled to a large size and with more
cars more congestion with more cars and
more sprawl comes more congestion and
ultimately more traffic fatalities the
World Health Organization estimates that
1.25 million people die each year
worldwide from traffic related accidents
over 2000 of these deaths occur in the
city of Jakarta Indonesia alone
understanding that Jakarta took this
opportunity to realize that if we could
solve this problem
in the city of Jakarta we might be able
to solve it all over the developing
world as this story of increased wealth
increased population and increased
traffic accidents has perpetuated
throughout the entire world so at the
start of the summer we started by
framing the problem in terms of what the
actual safety
were for the city of Jakarta so I need
to really stress this point that anyone
who wishes to do a similar kind of
project partner with a city a government
anything like that first we had to spend
weeks and sometimes this could take
months even longer before we touched any
code figuring out what the exact local
problems were so we asked the city to
talk with us about what the safety risks
were that they were most concerned about
and these are going to vary by local
context in Jakarta specifically driving
the wrong way against traffic was a big
problem things like illegal parking
stopping motorcycles sitting on
sidewalks things like this were issues
specific to Jakarta that they were
interested in solving and again if you
were to do this elsewhere you'd have to
go through this process again and figure
out what are the specific issues that
are facing the city at the same time the
city of Jakarta also has several policy
levers available to it and in the same
vein different cities different
governments are going to have different
policy levers available to them in
Jakarta case in the medium term they
were interested in things like managing
their traffic signals better deploying
traffic stewards or traffic cops things
like that it's particularly busy
intersections to manage different
particularly intense or chaotic traffic
the issue with any kind of traffic and
safety analysis though is that data is
really hard to come by
the typical way that you might imagine
somebody trying to get gather data about
traffic in a city if someone literally
goes out to a street and starts counting
the number of cars that go by with a
clicker that's not sustainable for a
mega city the size of Jakarta or indeed
most cities that people live in
so what Jakarta did have instead though
is a massive amount of cameras posted
throughout the city over 5,000 in fact
with many more to come
basically we saw ourselves as an
intermediate step where Jakarta has
these certain safety risks and has
certain interventions that can apply but
it needs to know where and where it will
be more most effective with them to do
that it needed this data didn't have
this data in
had lots of video this is a great start
but we had to figure out where can we go
from this video to something that can
really help policymakers make a
difference so this gives you a sample of
what we started with which is raw video
footage completely unlabeled but you
could see there's a lot going on lots of
interesting stuff you have traffic you
have people driving all sorts of ways
multitude of different types of vehicles
so cars motorcycles bikes tuk tuks mini
buses a range of things that make this a
very interesting and real problem so
again before we get into the technical
solutions I want us to think for a
second about what it takes to go from a
situation where we have video like this
and what it would take to transform this
into data that a policy analyst can then
use to make a difference in their city
so imagine for a moment if you will
hiring a technician to do this job you
might imagine hiring somebody placing
them in front of a video camera and
having them watch this intersection for
a whole day marking events of interest
like whether someone drove the wrong way
on the road whether they stopped
illegally whether someone parked on the
sidewalk etc etc the problem is this
does not scale well at all as I
mentioned there are over 5,000 cameras
posted in Jakarta right now with many
more thousands to come once you start
thinking about the human resources that
would be necessary to watch these videos
it becomes intractable to be able to
have so many people we calculated
require 44 million person hours each
year just to watch the 5000 cameras that
we had act that are currently available
to Jakarta not only is this impractical
human beings are prone to make mistakes
it wouldn't even be feasible to expect
them to do so accurately and
consistently we saw this is opportunity
however whereas human beings may not be
great and it may not be scalable to have
them watch all sorts all these videos a
computer maybe will do this at scale
quite well we figured that this is an
opportunity to apply machine learning
and other techniques in order to extract
meaningful quantitative information and
create a database that can ultimately
inform city agencies and other
policymakers as they attempt to design
particular interventions for the city so
what does that look like basically we
had to go from raw video basically
pixels as far as the computer is
concerned it's a substantive meaning so
we're gonna highlight for you three
particular methods first detecting and
classifying objects so figuring out that
this is indeed a car in this video frame
second figure out get some sense of
motion this is a car that's moving and
third get some sense of the context of a
scene what is a road what is a sidewalk
when you put these pieces of information
together you suddenly get a sense of
something like a car that is moving
against traffic so I'll turn it over to
my colleague Gracey Jeff to talk about
these specific methods and how we did
this so firstly we decided to use an
object detection method in order to help
us localize and classify objects I mean
we were given video data with no labels
so this is just footage that comes from
the these intersections that my partner
just described so first we decided to
throw Yolo the model on it and it
actually performed surprisingly really
well so the problem however was using a
model like your look which was trained
using datasets which are not actually
localized to developing countries such
as Jakarta with mini buses and tuk tuks
and food cards on the road is that you
would also you would also need to sort
of find you in the model to include
objects which are actually local to the
to the context so we also needed to
understand whether or not the vehicles
or the motorbikes that we actually
detect and localize actually moving or
they're stationary well this is really
important
that a place like Chuck in a place like
Jakarta with huge like bad traffic jams
vehicles such as motorcycles usually
move on the sidewalk so we would
literally need to understand whether the
motorcycle which we detected it's moving
or stationary otherwise if we would need
to understand something such as cars
which have illegally parked which is
really something which is common in an
intersection like this from the data
we've seen that a car would just would
just park just next you see that black
car over there it'll just park over
there and then causing a traffic jam
perhaps taking someone out of that
waiting for someone to get out of the
car so we would need to understand
whether or not it's moving so we used
optical flow and how that actually apply
it was a bad really wall in this case
was that for the objects which we have
detected using yellow and localized we
were able to just look at them and then
look check if the actually moving or
stationary finally we applied a semantic
segmentation model to sort of just get a
sense of the scene understand what road
where the road is where the sidewalk is
and where other things are actually so
that at the end we can actually say that
a motorcycle is moving on the sidewalk
this is particularly really dangerous
because it actually forces pedestrians
to be on the road to make way for the
motorcycles so these are the methods we
actually applied in order to help our
partner actually reach the requirements
that which they were interested in
however we had over 700 gigabytes of
video data it's a fairly high quality
data as well so we employed like more or
less a streaming approach where we
processed
um segments 15-second segments of videos
at a time through the pipeline so we
would get actually
so we would actually allow the partner
to decide whether or not they want to
connect this pipeline to the live video
cameras they have for the aerial team
and of analysis or perhaps for a long
medium to long term approach they could
just do this in the background and then
look at the data collected later so
going back to the requirements a partner
actually was interested in imagine we
are finding a motorcycle moving on the
left side which is against traffic as
per our client would have our partner
would have specified on the sidewalk so
this would then be flagged in the
database as a violation and if a car is
has stopped on the road then this is
illegal parking which is a violation our
partner might be interested in so so
this is the this in the scene I don't
know if you can notice a motorcycle
moving against traffic these are the
kinds of problems our part is actually
interested in flagging in order to
inform more medium to long term goals of
budgeting and planning on roads way to
deploy traffic officers or - AHA they
can actually give evidence in order to
request more budget in terms of getting
more traffic stewards so at the end a
solution looks something like this where
we can actually find problematic scenes
like this so these are the other cars
which are moving against traffic so
that's the wrong lane and then our model
is actually able to flag this these
events if you just all the first three
blocks these are the violate these are
violations which happened on the same
day within two hours so the fourth one
happened like two days later but then
this was just a sample from the data set
we have
these are the sort of the proper sort of
problems the city of Jakarta is facing
and it's actually interested in solving
to help improve traffic safety in the
long term thank you
thank you any questions
I thank you that was very interesting I
was wondering if you could use this kind
of data to calculate the the speed at
which cars are moving and if and if it's
if it's not only a way to deploy
punishment for bad behavior but also to
facilitate maybe new planning of roads
putting that Street it wouldn't know
one-way or building a parking lot where
people are stopping for no reason
something like that thank you
that's actually a really interesting
question but when you're when the the
problem were actually dealing with in
Jakarta had a lot to do with not only
the problems with traffic but also
things like power outages so you just
get random parties and it's really
difficult to get like sequential frames
yeah it's so capturing data like that
but however because of the traffic jam
in Jakarta it's really difficult to
speed so one of the first questions we
asked our partner at the beginning was
what was the speed limit and this is in
a room full of like 12 people from
Jakarta and one knew what the speed
limit was so to your second point the
thing I would add is that we want to
clarify that this entire system is not
meant to be punitive at all and that
actually took a lot of conversations
with our partner to really clarify and
like work out the ethics of what it is
that we were doing so ultimately what we
delivered it doesn't identify a
particular vehicle or it does in it
can't be used really to assign a fine to
somebody by reading their license plate
or something like that we designed it
and the contract and the discussions
with them all very much specified that
this is being used to build a database
which will be used do the exactly the
sorts of interventions that you suggest
but really it's important to have these
conversations throughout the entire
process of developing
this kind of project because this is the
sort of thing where we had to concern
consider the ethics of what it is that
we were doing on make sure that
expectations were kind of clear on both
sides as to what ultimately we wanted
this system to be able to do yeah I
think it's working I think you sort of
started to answer my question my
question was about the ethical
considerations that you have to make
while working on a project like this
I've worked on projects that similar
projects that could be used for good
things but also inadvertently could be
used for surveillance my friend he just
texted me be like don't ask your student
questions so yeah just if you've thought
about this we have absolutely thought
about this and we've actually spent
maybe half of the time in meetings just
trying to sort of reiterate and just
change the apartness
mindset about potential uses of a system
like this but but then what a lot of
things which which we have actually
realized in these kinds of conversations
that this particular partner for example
who we were working with it's almost
like these are problems they haven't
faced before so it's like you're
introducing a new technology and then
they'll be exploring and maybe someone
will flag something I'm about maybe
ethics and then debate and then lawsuits
and things like that they haven't
actually went through that kind of
process so it was really important for
us to actually walk them through the
kind of implications which may arise
from them asking us things like can we
can we actually track crowds and
identify people can you take snapshots
of scenes
so we had to have a lot of these
conversations with them about that they
can't just do that
and then try to explain and walk through
them walk them through what privacy
actually means for the building systems
which are meant for the public and which
are which actually meant for good any
more questions
thank you
[Applause]